well it seems quite a bit and originally
it really was focused on one particular
clause of the constitution which is the
Equal Protection Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment and that's the home
of the quality guarantee in the
Constitution it says no state shall deny
any person within its jurisdiction the
equal protection of the laws and some
people say right now the Bush
administration that it looks at the
Constitution and it sees only the
article 2 which is the presidential
powers portion of the Constitution in
what my early days i looked at the
constitution and i really only saw the
equal protection clause that that was
really the key part of the document and
that was what it was going to build my
career on and for the first five years
of writing i was writing about how gays
fit and didn't fit you know within that
portion of constitution how racial
minorities fit and didn't fit how women
fit and didn't fit and as time goes on
it's been a very happy moving for me and
it actually goes back to your earlier
question which is to say that i see that
the Equality guarantee is a really
critical part of the Constitution but
it's only one part of a very broad array
both of Rights and of powers and we have
many many other kinds of Rights that are
important from a civil rights
perspective so that in this key case in
2003 Lawrence versus Texas where the
united states supreme court struck down
a Texas sodomy statute Justice Kennedy
did not say this is a gay rights case
even though he and the rest of the
country understood that as a gay rights
case he said we're not going to decide
this under the Equal Protection Clause
we're going to decide this under the
Liberty clause and what we're really
talking about in this case is the right
of all people in the United States
whether they're gay or straight or
bisexual or choose to identify in some
other way to have sexual privacy so what
you do in your own home with another
consenting adult is your own business
and so he actually based it on the
Liberty provision of the Fourteenth
Amendment the Due Process Clause and I
felt like that was a really important
decision because
it changed the case from a case it was
only about a tiny tiny subset of the
American polity to a case it was about
all of us you know that everyone on the
Supreme Court you know everyone supreme
court was addressing when that opinion
was read out and the country as a whole
so as I get older this goes back to your
question of is getting this identity or
is it something else is it a kind of
conduct you know as I get older and more
mature and my understanding the
Constitution I see that civil rights
can't simply focus on the quality
provision and group based equality it
has to focus on universal Liberty is not
just in the substantive due process
clause of the fourteenth amendment but
also the First Amendment's free speech
rights the First Amendment's free
exercise rights and also an even more
subtle way and the powers provisions of
the Constitution's that articulate what
both and it and the limits of federal
governmental and state governmental
power are because often times we find
freedom where governmental power ends
you